Hey guys, how's it going? Justine here, and this is my new TV
And I am so extremely
Excited about the television because I saw this at CES this year and it was one of those things they see a CES and you
Think this is never going to come out. It's not going to be real. It's too cool
It's never going to happen and here. It is sitting in my office. I'm kind of in disbelief. Let's get a knife or something
Something Sharp not too sharp. I'm
Currently, you're waiting for the installation person to come it's about 6:30 in the morning
Got up really early because you never know when they're actually going to show up, so I've got to be on my guard
And I got to get this thing unboxed before they get here cool. It's an unboxing if I don't actually do the involvement oh
Gosh, I'm so excited
Episode welcome oh boy. All my goodness gracious
I'm a little bit concerned about this to people thing you're shy just wait, then these people come and do this for me
So here's the thing with this TV. It is so extremely thin that it's a television
That is basically meant to only be mounted on your wall. It doesn't have a stand
It's way too stingy to stand up on its own. Let's see what the accessories are installation cables manual remote battery
Here's our remote
What is that not a remote?
Some directions since I'm not installing somebody else is probably going to need these
So here's a bunch of the pieces that we're using for installation screws
cables
Stuff I'll put this over here. What's in here? Ah?
So this is very important. This is a substantial
Piece of cable now let's look inside. Oh
Wow
Okay, I am not going to be able to do this so I don't want to break it. It's so fragile
I don't think I trust myself trying to get this out of here. This is it right here, so in shock
This is this look right here
Now I shouldn't I shouldn't do this. I think it wouldn't be responsible and let someone else more responsible do this for me
This is the TV that's going to be replaced. It's actually which is the TV for my guestroom?
Here's another issue. Is this TV even going to fit here?
This is a 55 inch TV and to be completely honest with you
I didn't actually do any measurements, so I'm not even sure if it's been put on this wall
Music
It's officially
Finally fed up and I've had so many friends over and we've all just been sort of sitting here and odd
And there's no way that I can even explain to you in this video what it looks like in real life because it looks
So real it's like you're looking into a poster. It's not even on and I'm beyond impressed
I just feel like I'm not going to be able to do it justice in this video because I can't show you what I'm seeing
With my real eyes through this camera
Like it's dinner my iphone how does that even work?
Well, it works because the oled screen is connected by this white cable that goes into the sound bar and the sound bar is basically
Where powers the television and I've a few my inputs where you can put your games your TV and whatever else you want to input
Into the TV into the sound bar. It's basically like magic, so this setup
It's not my final setup because it's a lamar is actually a lot bigger than I thought it was going to be and clearly it
Does not fit on this stand I?
Wanted to see what it looks like in my office before I decided to drill through the wall because I would love to get this
Cable Hidden behind the wall, and then it'll go into sound bar the cable isn't that obvious but for me
I
Definitely want to have it hit you so stay tuned for a future video where I can show you guys the final final final of
My office what the speakers just rise right out of the sound bar and it is use like a magical magical
Experience to sit here. Just be like look. What are you doing? Let's get over there get some aside and see like
Like I feel like these trees to just be coming out and hitting me in the eye. Oh it smells so good
Have you compared it to how thin it is like something? No? I haven't yet. Which I can hair
Looking hair is only
Can you believe it like it's thinner than my iPhone oh?
huge figure
Okay, it's finally like two or three Sd. Cards two and a half SD card
Pretty Crazy Creason, there's also an extender table
So if I do mount this and then I want to put this somewhere else they've got that option you like it
This is loan, so we're going to plug in an attend a switch and place a Mario Kart
So the remote control also acts as like a pointer, so look point to check it out. How that employer
Disconnect us Mostly a Mario car
It's just us all the new velvet you'll see val what yes wait what yes wait, why didn't you tell me?
I'm telling you now, okay, Justin saw the DLC
It's downloading
But now I wanna play some Mario kart and do a quick little test to see what this feels like game on
Oh, yeah, 200Cc, baby. Let's do it
It's so fast
Where am I going?
Hahaha, oh, baby
just disregard everything that you saw right there a
Very poor performance on my part if thing is going to look so good on the Xbox Scorpio
Just being yourself addict
It's so perfect
bing
oh